district 12 is very first volunteer  listen to me you're stronger than they  are you are what do I need to do your  job is to be a distraction so people  forget what the real problems are  Katniss Everdeen they think she is it is  the only thing stronger than fear the  game ladies  because of her they all pose a threat  because of her they all think they're  invincible she has become a beacon of  hope for them miles  people are looking at you Katniss you've  given them an opportunity they just have  to be brave enough to take him  the Mockingjay myths days our great  nation has known only peace  ours is an elegant system received to  nourish and protect  your districts of the body capital is  the beating heart  more hard work to discuss  and in return they feed and protect you  if you resist the system